brut c'est thomas
on va là c'est l'heure de la relève on
va sur le phare première chose qu'on
fait quand on arrive on met ce qui a
trait aux frais le parent au congélateur
le chocolat dans son placard plateau et
ensuite serrés visite qui vont commencer
comme la merde laissant tout le monde
peut accéder ici que ça se passe
maintenant
cette mini cirque arts d'anvers ce
magnifique de retard
[Musique]
justement vous une embardée la partie le
sourire la construction du pape
[Musique]
à la fin des visites pour fermer les
portes là aujourd'hui on a reçu à peu
près 250 visiteurs et une trentaine de
plaisance et jeudi au pouvoir a fuité
vieux on a quand même des choses c'est
bientôt quatre ans moi je suis arrivé de
prendre un été en saisonnier au début et
puis je suis là surtout les était donc
là tout ça c'est la courage ça commence
par les cuisines accusés
après on a nos quatre chambres avec
notre gardien
voilà quoi ça ressemble donc c'est un
petit peu sombre parce que tout est
boisé landrier parquet c'est encore dans
son jus c'est eux les planches et
napoléon iii nous dit pas dans les
pattes un jeu toujours avec les patins
ici celle des carburants
donc comme je disais il nous faut du
gasoil de temps en temps pour les
groupes électrogènes et puis pour le
chauffage nous donc on allait aux cuves
à gasoil ici de ce côté et puis c'est
notre petit atelier avec tous nos outils
il ya toujours besoin de bricoler des
trucs réparer des trucs c'est une grande
maison en pleine mer où il ya plein de
trucs qui s'abîme
c'est ce qu'ont fait d'un gardien faire
après ça il ya du mur sur beaucoup de
femmes si je me suis beaucoup de
magazines phares qui fasse du club
mais oui dont j'imagine et quand même
que le travail
même plus partait sur
le feu sur sa fonction sur la
signalisation aux marines sur le secours
au bateau est pas du tout le cas quand
j'ai su travailler la règle change ma
famille je les pattes et en fait j'ai
mis un peu de temps de le dire parce que
je voulais être sûr ce canard je
m'éparpille beaucoup les vilains plus
scabreuses
j'avais bien parce qu'avant de m'étendre
sur le sujet j'avais eu envie de vanité
moi d'abord d'être sûr que ça me
convenait parce qu'on vient ici on est
absolument sur rien super l'album suit
fou que ça que ça se passe quoi dans un
lieu un lieu qui est exceptionnel parce
que le bâtiment lui exceptionnel mais
c'est tout l'environnement aussi qui est
assez incroyable pouvoir travailler
comme ça au milieu de l'océan on n'est
pas au milieu de l'océan à proprement
dit on habite laisse faire mais en face
à l'océan ouais c c'est génial asereje
[Musique]
balcons royal chine au premier étage ça
fait tout le tour
nous on va nettoyer un peu là parce
qu'en fait tout la gouttière qui est là
c'est la récupération de tri ça va bien
jusqu'ici
c'est pas mal de nettoyage
c'est pas mal de balles et c'est pas mal
de balles est pas mal de cuivre à
astiquer pas mal de plancher à cirer moi
j'ai beaucoup bougé j'ai habité dans
plusieurs disques pays différents mais
finalement je n'ai pas très loin d'ici
je suis né sur la côte vendéenne et
grandit sur la côte vendéenne du bain je
suis parti très loin d'ici qui c'est
marrant je me suis retrouvé pas très
loin comme ça au bord de la mer de
nouveau de la vie parce que je pensais
vraiment j'ai imaginé le gardien de
phare coupé du monde et en fait on a des
moyens de communication on a beaucoup de
touristes qui viennent nous voir tous
les jours en été et en hiver on a les
ouvriers qui vivent avec nous sur le
sabre on est un peu à l'écart quand même
l'écart du monde et on vit avec les
horaires de marée on vit pas avec la
montre on vit avec la météo un peu plus
connecté avec les éléments sur no et moi
ça c'est plaisant
[Musique]
ça fait en fait à l'intérieur il ya une
ampoule enfin si puissante que ça
a fait 250 watts et ça éclaire quoi s'il
faut que ça en fait tous ces crises mme
chaque fois que des ce triangle de
verbes et quand la lumière traverse un
triangle même change de direction donc
les rayons de lumière qu'ils aillent
vers le haut ou vers le bas
quand ils sortent de la lentille unis
vont tous vers l'horizon
[Applaudissements]
lowe's
on reconnaît ses trois en trois secondes
une seconde
[Musique]
voir s'ouvrir aux gens qu en fait tout
le temps la marée est haute
isolé sur le phare est un ver toujours
tour derrière la porte et dès que ça
commence à baisser et des complots et à
la porte les premiers bateaux arrivent
et voilà on est ouvert
sur la bia
j'aime bien et j'en ai comme ça moi
parce qu'on peut espace confortable
c'est pas le farsi ou mentale et
magnifique qui est grandiose
pourquoi encore
halfaya l'entretien du bâtiment et de
via l'accueil touristique aussi wacey
avait pas tourista monde qui a des
chances parce qu'elle est apte ou inapte
à la
pour préserver le patrimoine et puis le
pour les dents
jours